- [Instructor] When you
hear the word gravity,
you probably just think of things falling,
like an apple from a tree.
But did you know it's also the reason
why your lamp is staying on the floor?
That's because gravity is so much more
than things falling down.
Gravitational forces are
these invisible forces
that pull objects together.
So gravitational force
is actually attracting
the lamp to the floor
and these forces exist
between all objects with mass.
So let's write these key points out
about gravitational
forces, which I'm going
to use GF to represent.
We said they are attractive forces,
and that they exist between
all objects with mass.
Objects with mass, to explain this,
we first need to remember
a couple of things.
Mass is how much matter objects have,
and matter is the stuff
an object is made of.
Any object with mass generates
a gravitational pull.
So, there is a gravitational force
of attraction between every object.
The amount of gravitational force
between two objects will
depend on two things:
the masses of the two objects
and the distance between them.
The mass of each object is proportional
to the gravitational force.
This means that the
more mass an object has
the stronger it's gravitational force.
And, now, we can understand
why gravity makes things fall.
The Earth has massive, literally.
It's almost six septillion kilograms.
That's a 6 with 24 zeros after it.
So, it generates a huge attractive force.
For comparison, my lamp
is only one kilogram,
which is why if I jump, I fall towards
the Earth and not towards my lamp.
But we said the mass of the object
is just one factor affecting
the strength of its gravitational force.
The other is the distance between objects.
The more distance between the objects
the weaker the gravitational
pull between them.
For small objects without much mass,
it doesn't take much distance
for their gravitational forces
between each other to be so
weak that we don't notice them.
For something like the Earth, you have
to go really far away to not be affected
by its gravitational force of attraction.
I mean, look at the moon, it's
almost 240,000 miles away,
that's almost 400,000 kilometers away,
and it still feels effects
from Earth's gravity.
That's why it's orbiting
us, but since the moon
is also a pretty massive
object, we do experience
the effects of its
gravitational pull on the Earth.
This is why we have tides,
the moon's gravitational force
will pull on Earth's water, which results
in us having high and low tides.
Now, you might be wondering if
gravity can affect the moon,
or cause tides, how can
we even move around?
Why aren't we just face
planted on the ground
because Earth's gravity
is pulling us towards it?
It turns out that actually
gravity is a pretty weak force.
We only even notice its
effects when an object
is massive, like planets or stars,
and the gravitational force on you
is way weaker than most
forces you exert every day.
In fact, every time you
pick up a glass of water,
you're overpowering the
entire mass of Earth.
How cool is that?